okay so she-hulk episode 1 has just
released and it is a major thing for
hulk's future though it initially seemed
like thor ragnarok was going to be the
closest we'd get to world war hulk it
actually seems like the studio is going
to be returning to sakaar in order to
play out more of that storyline a world
war hulk movie has been rumored for a
number of years but after we got smart
hulk it seemed like that wouldn't be
happening due to him not being the rage
monster that was in that story it also
featured characters like korg and meek
so in the end many of us just assumed
that the trip to the planet in ragnarok
along with a gladiator fight would just
be the mcu's adaptation of it however it
looks like this isn't the case and
throughout this video i'm going to be
joined by jared as we move through our
thoughts and theories on what could be
happening if you enjoy the video then
please hulk smash that thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the video now world war
hulk is basically a continuation of the
planet hulk storyline this in of itself
was part of a trilogy that began back in
the planet hulk prologue in this nick
fury reached out to bruce banner who had
been hiding in the wilderness this is
because hulk had been on a massive tour
of destruction and therefore was lying
low due to the devastation that he had
caused nick wanted him to help on a job
that involved flying into space to
destroy a rogue ai that had been on
board a satellite and halt completed the
task by putting an end to this threat
however rather than returning home the
illuminati appeared on his shuttle
screen and like the worst surprise party
ever they told him that they were
actually blasting him into space because
of how dangerous he was the entire group
had agreed on this and it was safer for
earth to have him no longer a part of it
the shuttle then sent him to the planet
sakaar which the illuminati had said was
a lush garden planet that he could live
out the rest of his days in peace this
was basically an instagram versus real
life scenario though because upon
arriving he discovered that this was a
complete [ __ ] hawke's satellite
crash landed on the planet and due to
him being weaker from this crash he was
easy pickings he was fitted with an
obedience disc and slowly we uncover the
truth of what is actually going on here
now cigar was basically an empirical
society overseen by an emperor known as
agmo azan he ruled with brutality and he
created a society based on the back of
enslavement hulk found himself being
forced to become a gladiator upon
arriving on sakaar and this is somewhat
similar to what happened in ragnarok the
emperor was changed up to the grand
master and rather than creating a
rebellion hulk participated in the games
now the comics had him slowly standing
up to his captors and amongst the other
gladiators he ended up forming a war
bound pack the ones we met were korg
meek hello kaphai ski and hero him now
else the first two of these have
featured in the mcu there's still the
other characters that could be brought
across now their matches on the planet
had a big cameo and at one point hulk
fought the silver surfer who had also
been enslaved after crash landing on the
planet with marvel studios now owning
the film rights to the old shiny mr
clean in the fantastic four they could
potentially bring him into the universe
this way this would allow us to also get
a tease to galactus who could come in
after this in the comics after the
surfer was beaten and freed of the
emperor's control he actually offered
hulk a way out he said he could return
to earth with him but hulk unfortunately
turned this down hold on how cool would
a hulk and silver surfer buddy comedy
cosmic road trip movie be like hulk on
the front of his surfboard posing like
rose and jack in titanic sorry i'm
getting off topic now hulk ends up
breaking free of his captor and races
across the planet with the other rebels
the people of the planet believe that he
was the prophesized sikarson who was
foretold would free everyone of the
emperor's new rule hulk eventually
defeated him and he took over the planet
as its new king he was then joined by
the emperor's most ferocious warrior
kiera who he ended up marrying now
there's this great bit in the book where
they gotta consummate the wedding hey
and hulk actually transforms back into
banner so that she can see his true self
everyone else on sikar thought that he
was this giant warrior but it showed the
softer side to him that she fell in love
with the pair ended up expecting a child
but unfortunately everything came to a
tragic end the shuttle that brought hulk
across to earth was turned into a
monument but it self-destructed killing
his wife along with it this clearly
isn't how things will go down in the mcu
as they could severely mess up the
timeline however it is possible that the
hulk will have fathered a child on the
planet at some point in the comics the
kid managed to survive the explosion and
he was kept safe in a cocoon which hulk
didn't know about he went on to become
the character scar which could
potentially be someone who pops up very
very soon now in this episode we learned
that the sicarion ship is a courier
craft that's there to deliver a message
therefore i think it's possible that
this could be bringing with it news that
hulk has a child if you think about it
he spent two years on zakar and was seen
as one of the most high profile figures
due to the gladiatorial arena that
constantly saw him as the champion of
seems like they could be retroactively
saying that the green monster was
playing hide the cucumber had a kid and
this could be what the hulk was called
back for now in the box scar fell into a
lake of fire after being fired out in
the cocoon when he emerged she was a boy
rather than just being a baby he was
found by a character called old sam who
raised him and this could mean that when
we meet him he's not just starting off
as a kid interestingly scar was exiled
to earth and upon arriving here he
caused a lot of devastation she hulk and
the fantastic four ended up going head
to head with him and norman osborne
unleashed bombs that seemingly killed
him whether scar was still alive and he
actually transformed into a human much
like his father over the years he's been
a sort of villain slash anti-hero and at
one point he even joined the dark
avengers though he was revealed to be a
double agent for steve rogers there is
the potential that they could use these
storylines in the future to flesh out
certain things now one theory i have
about scar is that his dad was simply
called to just come pick him up if he's
been causing problems on the planet then
this is how they could have reached out
to bruce to reign him back in and this
is how the two of them could return to
earth if he's in hawke's custody he'd be
protective of him but scar could end up
going cuckoo could chew on the planet
just like how he might have on sakar
this could set up a world war hulk
storyline in which bruce has to protect
his son at all costs we've seen
something similar in civil war where cap
puts his neck on the line for bucky and
the same thing could be happening here
now they may totally avoid that but i
can't think of another reason why hulk
would be called back to his car i mean
aside from maybe for getting his
stretchy pants at the dry cleaners
however if we cast our minds all the way
back to the ending of ragnarok then we
know that the grand master was likely
captured and overthrown though love and
thunder did have a scene where he was
actually killed by gore however this did
end up being a deleted scene so we
shouldn't really classify it as canon
for the character therefore he could
have just been driven out and sakar
could end up needing a new leader now
this could lead to them looking to bruce
who was the most powerful thing on the
planet at one point this could
technically go off into the planet
hulk's storyline with us then getting a
mistaken attack by its forces hulk may
then travel back to earth and we could
get the seminal world war hulk storyline
that i'd love to see on the big screen i
think the way that they're laying things
out also means that we could move away
from the slightly more needed hulk that
we get in chi hulk the arm device being
destroyed means that he'll remain in
this form and when he gets to zakat they
could use things to push him even
further the comics had these horrendous
creatures called the spikes that were
basically parasites that alter their
host's behavior they might even end up
doing something like that with them to
change him into the angry green giant
again and i hope that we get more of the
old school hulk back now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on what you
think could happen below it's the mcu
and they won't do a beat for beat
recreation of that story but i think
they're definitely putting the pieces in
place for it at the moment comment below
and let me know and huge thank you again
to jared for joining us on this video
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
and theories you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want to be able to
watch them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the episode which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the easter eggs in it the callbacks
to the comics and it's definitely worth
checking out if you have any questions
over what's going on without the way
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace